my name is Duane spradlin and the CEO of
InnoCentive com
open innovation is the notion that
organizations that have traditionally
looked inward to create products to
create scientific breakthroughs things
that advance their business typically
are using people that look in act a
certain way it's the four walls of the
enterprise the traditional not invented
here open innovation tries to smash that
paradigm and says you should be dealing
with individuals and organizations from
all over the world what's important is
pushing your business or your foundation
or your mission forward it's less
important how you get the innovations
you need to do that
an organization that wants to be an open
innovation style company as an example
will typically look at all of the
projects in their portfolio all the
strategies all of the ways forward and
they will portfolio manage those into
different kinds of initiatives and
agendas that need to be pushed forward
as a business and then they'll choose
very strategically which of those will
go to the outside world which to the
inside world they may decide a new line
of business really needs to be acquiring
another company that's been done more
traditionally but when you get down to
brass tacks and you say you know what we
need a you know we need a new surface
material for a product we want to take
to market or we want to invite our
customers in to help us redesign the
next generation wireless network routing
technology right that's when
organizations typically fall down a bit
so in this new world these are these
large organizations are saying from the
top down you know a substantial portion
of our innovation is going to come from
the outside world we are going to look
at every one of our projects and we're
going to look for opportunities to put
those on the outside actually if we did
it right we'd say we should look for
opportunities to do it on the outside
and only do some of this innovation on
the inside if we have to the
organization's would structure so
they're better at product management the
financial management they should be
calculating ro eyes on every possible
project and you essentially realize then
that you've got an organization that's
focused on you know doing innovation
wherever it happens wherever is the best
place to do the innovation companies
should really decide whether the the
world is their laboratory or the
laboratory is their world and for
companies where the laboratory is their
world they tend to be inward thinking
for companies where the world is their
laboratory it's an entirely different
mindset and structurally they're
organized to make that happen
a business whether it's a large business
a small and medium business should be
thinking about what's profitable right
where's the product I should be taking
the market Who am I going to sell it to
etc how do I build the right communities
customer communities employee
communities partner communities and by
the way all of those communities are
sources of innovation and that becomes
part and parcel to this notion of a
constant innovation model and so in the
open innovation world these sustainable
businesses are focused much less on
having to invent every piece of what
they do and much more in creating a
sustainable structure with which they
can constantly innovate so when you look
at businesses that are now really
learning how to tap their customer base
user driven design you know it's you
know you know five years from now I
think everybody's gonna look back and
say that was intuitive but the reality
is five years ago what you actually had
to do to have a user driven design style
business was not done very often people
really saw writing you know starting to
get their hands you know their hands
dirty trying to make it work today
companies that get you know the killer
business model right can effectively
mine their communities and can create
constant innovation through the use of
their communities and application of
their business models will be the
businesses that I think strive in the
21st century and it's even more so
because now we're living in a world
where you can get to market instantly
you can outsource manufacturing other
structures instantly so it's the better
business model it's who are your
communities and mine them effectively
and creating a structure to let you
constantly innovate that's the winning
ticket
from an organizational point of view it
really is about talent management and
now the tools are changing but the words
are often the same right it's about
attracting talent right retraining you
know you know developing talent and
retaining talent so in this new world we
see much more of a shift towards
variable talent models and certainly
engaging open innovation is a structure
that allows organizations to you know
maybe the next 20 maybe the next 20
heads I hire I don't actually hire i
virtually hired them i get access to
them through some of the global open
innovation networks where i get access
to them through finding the right
partners to help me move ahead as a
business and that may very well be a
superior economic for me as a business
to manage risk and costs looking at this
through the open innovation lens it's
also a way for me potentially to get to
market better faster and more
cost-effectively it's not just the
offset of cost but in a world with seven
billion people six billion people you've
got people all over the planet that may
actually have better ideas to solve a
problem they may actually be able to
bring you know to bear some kind of an
idea from another industry that it would
have never occurred to my organization
what innocentive does is we've got a
network today of almost 180,000 what we
call solvers from around the world 200
plus countries sixty percent of them
have masters and PhDs they have
backgrounds and everything from
aerospace engineering you know to you
know to civil engineering chemists to
you know doctors and what they are what
they are is they're available to work on
problems now to answer your question in
our style of innovation it's not about
managing the workforce we do that via
the model we engage in for the
enterprise so if the enterprise has been
able to identify effectively that it
needs a you know a new kind of a
material for a product it wants to take
the market and it's been unable to
develop that material what it will do is
it will work with innocentive or another
party and develop a what we call a
problem statement in that problem
statement is a well-defined need and
success criteria coupled with an
inducement call it a prize so for fifty
thousand dollars if anybody in the world
can solve this problem for me for fifty
thousand dollars I'll take that
intellectual property and and and gladly
pay you the prize now this is a really
important model because what it does is
it changes the question from how do you
manage a global workforce of smart
intelligent creative people to how do I
get everybody in the world who's capable
ready willing and able to work on this
kind of a problem you know going to work
on the problem for me and I really only
want to pay for success so this prize
based or inducement based model turns
out to be incredibly powerful
companies this time around I think have
been much more he's resistant you're
just fundamentally cutting their
innovation spend and I think it's a lot
more mature way of looking at the world
because what it's saying is we can't
control necessarily demand for our
products during the downturn but we want
to be ready and willing and able with
all the right products when the economy
comes back to capture the full
opportunity so we're going to be there
to take advantage of this crisis if you
will now that's important because
organizations then that you know
substantially cut head count that
substantially changed their their
business models that made other kinds of
changes to their business may very well
be at a disadvantage so in a crisis like
this the reality is you may not have the
money to innovate the way you did so
you've got to look at how do i do both
how do I continue to be innovative how
do I continue to get my products out to
market but I may not have quite the same
in the way of resources to put towards
innovation as I did before so that's
where something like open innovation
comes to bear because these companies
know they need to continue to innovate
they simply can't turn it off because
they'll pay for that for years but they
got to do more with the same or less
than they've ever had before the smart
CEOs right now we're using this crisis
as a vehicle not only for looking to
capture more market share when the when
the economy returns but as a fundamental
as a fundamental pivot point on which to
change the way their businesses operate
to make them more competitive in the
future
an organization called the oil spill
recovery Institute based in Cordova
laska was really formed as a partnership
between not-for-profit interests
government and the oil companies after
the exxon valdez spill now what they
were focused on was how do you clean up
oil spills in subarctic waters which is
requires a kind of a different way of
thinking oil in subarctic waters get so
cold it's almost like a solid you can't
pump it so what most people don't
realize is that there are still
something like 80,000 barrels of oil off
of prince william sound off the coast of
Alaska that still haven't been cleaned
up from the exxon valdez spill so you
know in the last couple of years i think
after really years are trying to figure
how to get the oil out and running up
against this problem of very very
viscous almost solid oil they put a
challenge on the innocent of network to
try to find a solution to this and in
about three months this was put out all
over the world and you know dozens and
dozens of really interesting innovative
creative solutions came in but they
awarded the winning solution to a
construction engineer from the Midwest
and what he recognizes that keeping oil
liquid in cold waters is not so
different than trying to keep cement
liquid as I'm pouring a foundation right
again organizations would have never
thought to look there that's the power
of diversity getting everybody involved
in solving a problem so it turns out
what he recommended is that if you will
off-the-shelf construction equipment
that vibrates the cement keeps it liquid
with slight modifications could be used
in the barge systems that are really
trying to pump the oil off the bottom of
the sound so they're doing that now and
what's most exciting about this for me
is the follow up that was a
twenty-thousand-dollar prize and this
gentleman John Davis flies himself to
Cordova Alaska to using the prize money
to meet the people he was helping and
now he's doing pro bono work for them
and the oil spill recovery Institute now
runs challenges routinely over
InnoCentive they call in a center of
their virtual laboratory we are their
laboratory but the real moralist story
for me is this he didn't do it for the
twenty thousand dollars he did it to
make a difference in the world and that
passion is probably one of the most
important currencies you can imagine
you